so kho is a drilling a training exercise
it's for that c moment that I
demonstrated yesterday yesterday's video
okay you you have
to uh be able to project their line of
gravity way outside of an athlete's
ability to reposition their basis
support back under it okay so when you
do a momentum
throw the athlete is always going to be
able to get their Bas of support back
underneath that line of gravity okay so
the art is based upon in part that CQ
projection okay and so here you're doing
a drill where you repeat over and over
over and over that moment that's what
drills do just work on that one moment
okay and so for the sake of repeating
that moment the projection moment uh
everything else is kind of idealized and
control it's irrelevant
okay so um I don't want to do any kind
of tilting of this
body I'm not doing this kind of
stuff so what is this kind of stuff well
in Ence you're taking his line of
gravity and moving it outside his b of
support you see that but as I turn him
here and he can she go underneath this
you see and then it's not going to work
so why did it work before because he
left his base of support there and then
he eventually will fall do you
understand that okay so that is to me
that is not called this is not
C this is just I don't know low level
momentum throwing got it okay so
um what we're doing is taking his uh
energy letting it pass through me come
down to the ground let it pass back out
through me rebound and that displaces
him like he gets like a jolt of like a
something pushed him okay but it's
energetic it's not with my actual hands
okay so we're going to uh take
out the final part even this part
because that's working on another aspect
of and we're just going to focus on
the projection part okay um so I am
going to he's going to by drill design
uh connect to my Center so he's not just
holding my wrist here okay what do I
mean by connect to my Center is he comes
in establishes the center relationship
to where a little extra and I can
project him out do you got it so I'm not
sitting here this
a and you could do that if that was your
role but that is not your role Your Role
is to get to Center here okay just prior
of projection so he's doing that okay
and I send that energy down it's not in
my shoulders send it down and now I am
going to increase his y value in this
drill so his pushing that's y I'm going
to increase it with a slight yield
boom and that is what I use to project
back out
I can increases y value with the my
exercise so you going to get the first
one you're going to come in and I'm
going to take that you see his intention
to come in his intention to grab and
feel my Center here I'm going to make
him continue that intention here but not
with this bent elbow okay so you'll get
one oh you'll come
in and I'm
loading some of the things you'll
notice my arms are not bending at the
elbows out you see
that
now what I I want to do as purely as
possible is to have his young energy
bounce off of me okay so that means my
arms don't have to go in and they don't
have to go out so pop I'm going to load
for this shape is
irrelevant where my arms
are doesn't matter
doesn't matter if it's two or one the
energy is coming in cuz I take advantage
of his intention bring it a little bit
past where he wanted it to go that
increases the Y value I let that rebound
off of me okay another thing you'll see
um is Bes side my arms not going in and
out and
extending my torso does not stay still
I'm not
going here
straight my body is moving see body
move here I
Y extend
yield it's not in the
arms okay
thirdly I'm not
bracing so I don't want to have this
pelvic tilt here where he's pushing and
I'm stringing the heck out of that your
back should be flat just like Zen so my
back is
flat never
here that's
terrible
okay what I can't do is uh tense up just
like I don't want to brace here I don't
want to extend my arms all of that goes
with trying to push him over and that's
not what we're doing we're trying to get
his energy to go through me and bounce
back out of me I'm not trying to push
him over got it it's different uh in
order to have his energy go through me I
can't be tense it doesn't go through me
it gets stuck here at his grip okay so
I'm very
relaxed don't pay attention to him pay
attention to my
arms
if I see how lo hands are stuff okay you
will block the energy if you tense up
here and it'll go superficial it won't
go internal
okay okay some other things so um that
are telling you you're not doing it so
we mentioned this stuff you see um and
then your torso is straight up and down
uh this saddle here okay same thing when
your butt comes
up if you're doing this right your butt
goes down butt goes down energy goes
down not
not that the energy is
down the other thing is
uh if he increases the pressure it's
easier to project it's harder to project
on people that do disengage the pressure
okay but if you're doing it
superficially
externally when they increase the
pressure that will get harder for you
okay so he's he's going to try to really
Jam me up you
see will be able to make smaller
movements and
[Music]
get
understand so uh let us you're going to
get tired because you're
like but if you try hard enough you'll
actually rest more because you'll
probably fold 90% of the class you get
it got it okay let's try
Ito kazushi is about reducing energy and
mass so the most efficient way of
creating a top Turvy effect is on this
diagonal here this diagonal here this
diagonal here okay do you got it uh but
that means if I'm trying to train that
is going to
be um a less efficient way of drilling
basically you're using less weight on
the bar if you're trying to do a bench
press and you're taking weight off
that's what you do in kazushi okay but
in drilling in kokuo you don't take the
weight off you try to keep the weight on
so to speak it's not really weight but
you're trying to keep as much energy in
the technique as possible okay so uh you
don't I don't want to tilt him and then
project tilt him and then project
s so if you pay attention uh especially
as he starts really shuing
me I'm not trying to do anything with
him uh elbows and shoulders and things
like that okay so to help you uh we're
just going to go back straight
back
shove okay got it so there's no lean of
his person or anything like that so same
drill as last time R is going to try to
overpower it uh what's going to happen
is that's going to kick in your fear
Instinct you're going to muscle on it
the energy will not pass through you it
will be superficial it be caught at the
grip they're likely going to overpower
you if they're stronger than you okay
instead they're going to push in you're
going to release pull and let it bounce
down back out and straight through their
Mass with no leaning whatsoever of their
Mass
okay it is important that you're not
thinking like oh skeletal alignment it's
not it's not skeletal alignment okay so
you can come back you see and you're
going to have
it you get it okay so uh why do that
work well energy was passing through me
here down to the ground just because I'm
moving my hand forward that energy is
still passing through me to the
ground do you get that so as I go
forward I'm not going forward this
energy is passive the energy of me
moving forward goes back through the
ground comes back out through the
hand
[Music]
okay try